The Washington Post career prosecutors
recommend no charges for Matt gates in
sex trafficking probe investigators see
credibility challenges for two main
Witnesses in a probe of the
congressmen's alleged past dealings with
a then 17 year old in other words
there's no evidence there's nothing
that's it just some people with no
credibility making accusations they
can't back up and so the prosecutors are
like ain't nothing we can do about it
we'll see they're saying maybe they'll
still bring charges but it'll be
extremely unlikely to do so considering
what they're saying now but here's what
happened they start the probe someone
leaks information to the press and then
all of a sudden it's it's it's law the
media just says it's happening and
that's what they do so my question is
with everything we've seen with the FBI
the Washington field office particularly
going after their political Rivals how
much of this was an extortion plot how
much it was it was because let's let's
just show you the context here this is
from Politico Florida man gets five
years in plot to extort Matt Gates's
father a U.S District Judge sentenced
Stephen Alford to 63 months plus three
years supervised release the story he
went to the family and said hey I can
make that all go away if you give me 25
million dollars so I'm starting to lean
towards whoever set this up the
investigators and then whoever was
leaking it they were all in on it
what do you think from your information
yeah I don't you know to me like I don't
have information so like I don't I I'm
very careful like I don't like to Lobby
uh lob accusations or you know at people
that where I don't have real information
so I will say that you know I my
instinct was that it was true based on
the coverage from every major paper you
know I believe them and what's that well
I believe them well especially so you
know
the last you know couple years of my
life dealing with some of the uh some of
the things I've dealt with definitely
has me questioning a lot more things
I'll say that but you know typically The
Washington Post does a pretty good job
you know disagree you know my opinion my
opinion that David Weigel fabricated a
story and they and then they secretly
edited it six months later and they
never they never like they never issued
a public correction he literally just
wrote a fake story about the Seth Rich
conspiracy Matt manufactured insane
claims that made no sense and then I
actually get him on the phone and he's
at the Washington Post and I'm like you
made this up and he's like
okay and then nothing happens six months
later they go in without saying anything
and they alter it to clean it up and
that's it no official correction no
public statements or anything The
Washington Post is just garbage and
that's just the easy example like at the
top of my head I'm sure there's I'm sure
there's plenty of examples everywhere
but this is them right now saying no
charges yep no I see it yeah yeah I mean
you know so who are these other options
and I will say that I will say that you
know if when all is said and done it
comes out that you know this guy is
innocent I mean that that's pretty
terrible but he was always innocent
but I mean everyone's innocent until
proven guilty right exactly so you know
so they just run fake stories in the
Press what they they play dirty games
like
these these liberals tend to think that
if you're accused of a crime you're
guilty of it that's a terrifying reality
well that that is the way the media
works right so like there's been a huge
Dynamic shift where you know it used to
be that like journalists took a long
period of time to get stories out make
sure that they had sources confirmed all
of them now because of the age we're in
where everyone is is creating news
quickly you know including like you guys
right
um it is a race to get the story first
which often means that the story is
inaccurate and once somebody launches
the story everybody races to tell the
same story and you end up getting this
confirmation bias yeah but this is
something different I mean this is
people leaking information on a story
that had no evidence or credibility sure
and in the media especially leftists
running it as if it was true yep I mean
let's be honest here there's a lot of
sex traffickers in Washington DC there's
no denying there there's a lot of sex
traffickers everywhere exactly yeah and
and it's important to note here that the
FBI has been moving according to the
latest whistleblowers agents off of
those cases and moving them on to the
January sixth cases and when it came to
this particular case I did find it
interesting because I I do follow a lot
of these stories I think they're
important to talk about especially when
it comes to things like the DC Madam
that's a whole nother crazy story that
if you want to go down a rabbit hole you
could go down a rabbit hole with but but
I didn't find any any evidence here with
Matt Gates I didn't see anything
legitimate I didn't see anything
confirmed so I kind of kept quiet about
it I waited as a journalist to see what
was going to be happening what was going
to be developing here but online all
over Reddit there was number one posts
calling him a sex trafficker sure but I
haven't seen anything legitimate I
haven't seen any evidence suggesting
this but everywhere on social media
especially in leftist circles he is
automatically deemed now a sex
trafficker which I think is a little bit
unfair since of course there's no
evidence providing this this assertion
which was spread out by you know
insiders from the government and then
regurgitated by the corporate media to
smear somebody
yeah I mean I think there's always a
bias against people you don't like if
you don't like somebody it's very easy
to believe bad things about them exactly
and you know and he's uh extremely far
right and you know is is a continuous
Target I I just can't help feeling like
this is a classic case of we were
talking about innocence until proven
guilt this is a case of the media
choosing whether to decide if someone is
guilty or not and going with it they
don't care about whether it's actually
true then if it's proven that they're
wrong they simply don't talk about it
I've seen them do this before so what
happens if they're if it's proven that
they're they've been lying or they've
been inaccurate or they've left
something out they just stop talking
about it I agree with it like I'm
genuinely surprised I'm proud of the
Washington Post for talking about this
at all like good for them but because
what they like to do is just swoop it
under the rug like Tim was saying with
this other story that after six months
months they went back and sneakily
edited it and didn't say anything about
it yep I think still to this day they've
never fixed it really yeah it's amazing
and now will there be a major retraction
from all these other organizations that
slandered him will all the people who
made fun of them
the the activists are already saying
stuff like
you know they just they know they can't
win but doesn't mean it's not true
yeah I mean like there's traffickers and
you know this because there's there's
victims coming forward Epstein had his
victims coming forward to the FBI in the
90s and there was people speaking out
against this and of course they didn't
do anything about it where's the victims
of gates coming forward like who is that
guy who um he called out Epstein nobody
nobody believed him and uh what was his
name you know Luke gradkowski no no no
no he had a big show
big information and he's he's in court
right now and it's kind of a show trial
or Alex Jones oh dude you got to see the
most recent clip of him going at it with
the lawyer who's like Target the lawyer
is whining really hard and Alex was like
so some base stuff it's pretty uh yo The
Alex Jones trial is hilarious there's
this clip I was watching it I was
watching the live stream of it and the
plaintiff's attorney asked him who he
gets his sales reports from and then
Alex is like uh
uh no no one and then he's like no who's
it who is giving it to you and then he's
like I'm not allowed to say and so then
they have to call like sidebar and the
judge actually says you were right to do
that because he would have to say it's
coming from the bankruptcy lawyers so
like the rulings against Alex are
actually inhibiting the plaintiff's
attorneys and then there was that other
clip that went viral where he said you
know he mentioned liberals morals
turning on a dime or whatever and all
the Iraqis they killed their lies yeah
the guy the lawyer was getting really
emotional and spring he's like you do
it's emotional when you want to be
emotional it's not when you don't I'm
sorry I gotta say about people's lives
being lost I gotta say the judge is
inadequate I'm being polite inadequate
I'm being applied to the judge because
when the plaintiff's lawyer starts like
just yelling at Jones and Jones starts
snarking back the judge did nothing and
then another lawyer was like judge are
you gonna do this there's nothing she
goes well I can't get a word in edgewise
it's like you're the you have a bailiff
you're a judge you can bang the gavel
and hold people in contempt and you're
sitting there letting people mouth off
and I don't know it's all for TV you
have a responsibility to do that as a
Justice that's your courtroom
whatever it's all for TV it was it we're
getting memes out of it and the videos
are funny and it's just all it's like
you know I'm watching that and uh uh I
can't remember who said it but they said
that the January 6 hearings are
basically like nightly entertainment for
wine moms they're like sitting there
going like oh what's gonna happen next
oh he did what and then they're voting
based on it it's kind of scary it is
yeah but it's it's more because it's
like if the FBI really is moving
Manpower out of like sex trafficking and
going into domestic terrorism I kind of
wonder what you'd think about this Nick
like why do you think that this is
happening do you I mean do you do you
think there's actually
um a risk of domestic terrorism
overthrowing American republicanism
no I I don't I mean you know I don't
think January 6th was a good thing I
don't think I think that people should
be held accountable so just you know
that that's my my position on that
um do I think that it was uh you know
like a big planned Professional Event
like I do not I I think it was a bunch
of idiots doing idiot things and
um humbling about you know what are they
called the Maga mimos yeah like I mean
like you know you look at that group and
like you know these people are not you
know this is not uh
you know like James Madison and and John
Adams I mean like that like that's not
what you had yeah this wasn't SEAL Teams
moving in um
you know yeah I mean you know it's a big
deal and I don't I think it should be
taken seriously
um but I I also don't think I think that
the press this is where I really get
aggravated with the Press we talk a lot
about Civil War right and I I think that
these people don't know what Civil War
is or they think it won't happen but
they think they can get clicks by
talking about it but you know there are
gonna be idiots that start believing
that there's like a real Civil War
that's forthcoming and you know why
wouldn't there be
why wouldn't there be
um
because
I'm not saying it can't happen because
it can happen anywhere
um I think that
Americans do not really want to
shoot their neighbor in the face thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there